you're a little scary sometimes you know
that
playing a villain is a dream come true
for plenty of actors as they're often
the most fun to embody so they take the
role very seriously and sometimes a bit
too far let's take a look at who thought
their co-stars were truly terrifying
we do not speak his name
what is honestly mind-blowing to think
about is the fact that daniel radcliffe
didn't even have any scenes with rae
finds until he was 15 years old meaning
the first scene they ever actually did
together was at the end of the fourth
movie goblet of fire when cedric's just
been avada kadavra oh i'd almost
forgotten you were here
raph has yeah genuinely uh scared me for
a few years we can't say we blame
radcliff for that when you've built up
this imaginary villain in your head it
only makes sense that he would
intimidate you
i didn't want to talk to rafe that much
this is not the first time harry has run
into other forms of the villain though
with voldemort being portrayed by
christian coulson in the chamber of
secrets and he was just ahead attached
to professor quirrell's head in
sorcerer's stone so we can imagine
that's just cgi and voldemort never
really appears in prisoner of azkaban
much at all but did you catch him in one
of the portraits he was even scarier
than alan was at first the gossip got
away from people when it came to suicide
squad jared leto did a lot of prep work
to get into character as the joker he
even sent a live rat in a box to harley
quinn actress margot robbie i wasn't
dead shot at all in that moment
yeah yeah it was pretty it was pretty oh
what we're wondering is if he gifted her
a pet rat or a rat off the street
because honestly that distinction makes
all the difference when asked about it
leto tried to shift the conversation
away from gifting rats to his kinder
gifts i found this place in toronto that
had great
vegan cinnamon buns
that isn't all the gifts leto was
feeling generous with because he
apparently also had a dead pig delivered
to the set once again was it for a pig
roast or was it just a pig because
context is really important here and we
want to know i think it freaked
everybody out but that was the point on
alan rickman's last day matthew lewis
went up to his trailer to give him a
proper goodbye even knocking on his door
terrifying he said to him hey i know
it's your last day and i just want to
say this has been
incredible lewis wanted to thank him for
treating all of the young actors like
his equal rickman invited him in for tea
and the two of them chatted about
louis's career going forward rickman
encouraged him to train in theater and
lewis followed him up on that advice
saying that he really learned about
himself from theater he regrets spending
all those years too afraid to approach
rickman and is glad he at least had that
moment with him the first time david dis
mulchin who played piter davreese got a
look at the baron was when the villain
emerged from a shroud of steam while
they were filming and it freaked
dissmalchen right out he just scared the
crap out of me it was awesome while
dismalchin found the prosthetic and
design of baron overwhelmingly
intimidating it was actually stellan
skarsgard's eyes and powerful voice that
intimidated him the most god i really i
really do love them going on a stone
note no i really do love jennifer
jennifer lawrence's friendship with josh
hutcherson runs deep and at the point in
filming where she sees peta on a screen
in mockingjay part 1 she actually hadn't
seen her friend in a long time because
hutcherson's roles were filmed
separately to get lawrence's authentic
reaction they actually played the final
footage of peta begging for district 13
to stop the footage where you could see
pito was being tortured the director
really believed the distance helped
suddenly seeing him up on the screen and
you know in pain and sort of tortured
was i think it worked well for her
emotionally apparently it wasn't hard to
get those real tears flowing it's pretty
cute to see she actually cares for
hutcherson as much as her character
cares for peta talk about good on-screen
chemistry
clowns are scary at the best of times
let alone when you're a young child and
nobody has prepared you for what you're
about to see even if it's for a shot or
like two or three takes
it was really worth it because you can't
really rely on young children's ability
to act you need to rely on authenticity
so the extra child actors that were
brought in never saw bill skarsgard
until the camera was rolling some
children looked away and some cried yeah
raw reaction first time we saw him it
was terrifying skarsgard honestly felt a
bit bad about it all stating if i
succeed at what i'm trying to do with
this character i'll traumatize kids and
adults if you ask us other than you know
the images that were released when we
were filming we didn't see them at all
heath ledger took his role as the joker
incredibly seriously he locked himself
away for six weeks to nail every
mannerism of the character the first
time michael kane saw heath ledger once
again while the camera was rolling the
guy froze in fear who are people gonna
be most scared by is gonna be joker is
it gonna be two-face joker joker the
joker would do it when the bloody door
opened on that lift he came tearing out
i forgot every line
kane isn't exaggerating and is quite
complimentary of the actor it's one of
the scariest performances i've ever seen
and maggie gyllenhaal had a similar
experience when he grabbed her her
immediate instinct was to try and pull
away she couldn't look him in the eye
which prompted the improvisation from
ledger to say
despite the fear he distilled in her she
loved it saying i actually had a great
time working with him because anything i
threw at him he would take it and throw
all sorts of amazing things at me lupita
nyong'o would work on her acting off
screen which freaked out her co-star
shahadi wright joseph she really kind of
um spooked me out a little bit because
she would like she would really get into
character and like wouldn't talk we'll
admit that would freak us out a little
bit too it was kind of creepy but
despite that shahadi said it was a lot
of fun for her to experience all those
other sides of lupita's character
remember the boat scene from willy wonka
and the chocolate factory it's a bit
hard to forget given how creepy it was
they didn't know what i was gonna do
imagine how it would have felt to be one
of the child actors on that thing
especially when the director didn't tell
the actors what gene wilder was planning
for the scene a chance to
be scared and terrified this uncertainty
made them uncomfortable but the creepy
song put it over the top for sure when
wilder started talking all crazy like
denise nickerson who played violet
thought that wilder was actually going
mad from being in the tunnel there
wasn't a whole lot of acting going on
just genuine fear and confusion
but i really let him have it shelley
duvall spent a lot of the shining shoot
actually in distress since the director
wanted to keep her crying as
authentically as possible this really
took its toll on duvall as the shining
still holds the guinness record for
highest number of retakes of a shot with
dialogue this leaves her in a very
vulnerable place for when she's acting
opposite jack nicholson the scene with
the baseball bat was absolutely
terrifying for her partially because the
danger felt so real but partially
because they took three weeks to film it
poor duvall said she'd cry when she woke
up in the morning over the idea of
having to cry more all day and she just
wanted the experience to end but she was
impressed by her co-star saying jack was
so good so damn scary you think maybe he
should be taken to a doctor
so actors can be scared of their acting
partners for all sorts of different
reasons surprise stress and
unpredictability are just some of the
mind games that happen in the studio and
then there is the physical side the real
danger the weird makeup and prosthetics
but behind the characters is quite often
a genuinely good person who just wants
to do a good job and maybe some of that
fear just isn't justified alan rickman
sounds like he was a big softy when it
came to children which experience do you
think would be scariest to you